[Música]
[Aplausos]
de aquí quienes saben leer en la mano
todos pero esta no es una realidad para
muchos según la unesco 250 millones de
niños en edad ir a la escuela no pueden
acabar de leer una oración completa
yo pensaba que esto pasaba en lugares
marginados lugares lejos hasta hace un
año conocí a pablo a pedro ya juan niños
de tercero a quinto de primaria de una
zona rural que hasta que al estar
hablando con ellos me dicen que no sabía
ni leer ni escribir bien
ese mismo verano en otro lugar a juanjo
un niño que conozco desde que él era
pequeño le pregunté cuánto leía y me
respondió que un letrero cada vez que
salía de su casa
a mi familia ya mi primero nos dio risa
pero después nos preocupamos por juanjo
él ya estaba en segundo de primaria y no
estaba leyendo lo suficiente
yo pensaba que por el simple hecho de ir
a la escuela aprendería a leer y
escribir pero no era así
y oportunidades de hacer un cambio llegó
rápido un trabajador de mi papá le pidió
ayuda con su hija y ahora de 1º de
primaria que estaba teniendo problemas
en matemáticas
mi papá hizo entonces lo que había hecho
con mi hermana y conmigo
le dio ejercicios para que hiciera todos
los días
en mis primeros años escolares mi papá
nunca se sentó a hacer la tarea conmigo
pero revisaba mis ejercicios de mate
cuando algo estaba mal llovía porque
sabía que me esperaba una semana llena
de ejercicios en los que me tendría que
sentar todos los días hacer lo que él me
dejara y si algo estaba mal él lo
borraba y yo lo tenía que volver a hacer
entonces mi papá sabiendo lo que yo ya
había experimentado me pidió ayuda para
generar estos ejercicios y le empezamos
a dar la tierra sumarse y restas del 1
al 10
una semana después otro trabajador se
dio cuenta de lo que estábamos haciendo
y pidió lo mismo para su hija valeria de
quinto de primaria y unos días después
también le estábamos dando tarea mi
primo mateo de 3º de primaria
sabíamos que había que involucrar los
papás entonces les dimos las hojas de
respuestas para que ellos calificarán a
sus hijos cuando ya no tuvieron errores
les dimos sumas y restas con números
cada vez más grandes
y llegaron las primeras calificaciones
y todos habían subido pero no solo en
mate sino también en sus demás materias
porque aparte de los ejercicios en los
que tardaban 1 o 2 minutos les pedimos
que leyeran 20 minutos diarios
y ahora paso de un 8 a un 10
valeria por primera vez tuvo 10 en todas
sus materias y mateo pasó de 17 a 19 y
así sabíamos que lo que estábamos
haciendo estaba funcionando
mis papás entonces empezaron a contar lo
que estábamos haciendo en reuniones
familiares y con amigos y así fuimos
obteniendo cada vez más niños hasta
tener 12 y a mi prima de 30 años
todos empezaron desde el mismo punto
pero cada quien avanzaba a su propio
ritmo había uno es que en las primeras
hojas se tardaron una o dos semanas y
hubo otras que tarde se tardaron una o
dos semanas más
mateo y valeria empezaban a hacer
multiplicaciones no era nada nuevo para
ellos pero tenían que perfeccionarlo
primero buscábamos que no tuvieron
errores y después de que lo hicieran en
el menor tiempo posible y eso lo íbamos
a lograr mediante el ejercicio
y entonces volvieron a llegar
calificaciones y los doce niños habían
subido
pero llegaron las vacaciones
y empezamos a perder niños
los papás les decían que no había
problema con que dejaran de hacer los
ejercicios por una o dos semanas y
después de las vacaciones regresarían a
hacerlo
pero nunca contestaron y otros que
simplemente no contestaron los correos
y así fue hasta solo tener a los 13
originales y ellos y con ellos también
perdimos contacto
el mayor problema fue que los papás
vieron demasiada mejoría en sus hijos
pensaron que habían llegado al límite de
sus habilidades
en el sistema escolar que actualmente
utilizamos medimos el desempeño mediante
números el 5 es la peor calificación y
el 10 es la mejor pero yo creo que el 10
es la peor calificación porque no hay
nada más allá de un 10 no llegas
no llegas a desarrollar por completo tus
habilidades llegas a desarrollar solo lo
que la escuela quiere de ti
de este sistema tan estandarizado lo
único que ha aprendido es a memorizar
pero no a memorizar por largos periodos
de tiempo sino a memorizar por uno o dos
días y no soy el único
cuál es el problema de esto si tenemos
estos aparatos
les puedes preguntar cualquier cosa como
porque ya no me ama
[Música]
y está en cuestión de segundos
tenemos a la información como nunca
antes al alcance de nuestras manos pero
seguimos memorizando
entonces que hay que hacer
ejercitar dejar de memorizar
que se nos ayuda a desarrollar
habilidades que la tecnología hace una
herramienta
que los maestros en lugar de ser figuras
de autoridad a las que les tenemos miedo
sean guías
que haya - juanes pablos y pedroso y que
haya más valeria y abrace y mateos hay
que salir de esta burbuja que es la
educación tradicional y buscar nuevas
formas de enseñar
nosotros somos los que vamos a tener que
resolver los problemas de hoy y una
buena educación va a ser la clave
tal vez sea muy tarde para mi generación
pero todavía estamos a tiempo para hacer
un cambio con los más pequeños gracias
[Aplausos]